We've got an addiction to oil in this country.
Coconut oil.
It's good for your hair, for your skin, for
cooking, for mental health, for … FOR EVERYTHING.
But is this real?
Or just another fad.
Is it just Facebook, Twitter and everyone
I know or are people are actually coo-coo
for coconut oil?
In the 1980s, coconut oil was considered terrible
cholesterol-causing junk.
Yet in 2002, the New Statesman published,
"People who eat coconut oil in place of other
vegetable oils" are free of degenerative diseases,
have a healthier BMI, and live longer.
And there's a rumor it can even cure Alzheimers.
Lucky for us, science has spent some time
looking into it.
A coconut isn't a nut (or fruit, or seed),
it's a drupe, like a peach or apricot.
Coconuts on trees are fleshy bits, each containing
a single brown pit or stone, which is what
we call the coconut.
Coconut oil is exactly what you think it is,
a result of processing the white meat of a
coconut, the endosperm, to extract its oil.
There are a handful of ways people accomplish
it, but they all end up drying, boiling, or
pressing its flesh.
The change from the 1970s and 80s to today,
is coconut oil production has gotten better.
Virgin coconut oil wasn't available then,
and instead it was a highly processed oil
product.
But is today's product really better?
Processed coconut oil contains 92 percent
saturated fat; butter is only 64 percent,
and both beef and pure LARD are only 40 percent.
Unlike animal fats, coconut oil doesn't contain
cholesterol.
Instead, it influences cholesterol in the
body -- which is manufactured by the liver.
Saturated fat causes inflammation in the blood
vessels, so we should keep an eye on it because
consuming a little coconut oil is going to
have a large impact on saturated fat intake.
Coconut oil ALSO contains medium-chain triglycerides,
or MCTs -- which are ALSO processed by the
liver, the main MCT in coconut oil is called
lauric acid, which is associated with increases
in HDL cholesterol (the good kind) and is
associated with decreased body fat, but it
also raises LDL cholesterol (the bad kind
which causes heart problems).
According to Dr. Walter Willett of the Harvard
School of Public Health, "overall effects
on health can’t be predicted just by the
changes in LDL and HDL."
And there just hasn't been enough time to
do long-term studies to figure out the true
benefits or drawbacks of the oil.
In 2011 a molecular biologist from University
of California Davis told the New York Times,
"there is no concrete scientific data yet
to support" the health benefits of coconut
oil.
So far this new coconut oil fad seems to be
driven by hype more than actual information.
People hear the media spout its health benefits
and throw it on ALL their foods; but moderation
is more important.
Chances are too much is going to cause more
harm than good.
Sure, the HDL boost is nice, but both soybean
and olive oils lower LDL and raise HDL; and
there are other compounds in the dregs of
this drupe which may affect the body in other,
as yet unknown, ways.
With regard to Alzheimer's, coconut oil has
no scientific evidence to support it, only
a book written by a pediatrician about her
husband's experience with Alzheimer's.
What we DO know, is coconut oil works for
baking as a substitute for butter, vegans
have tested that for us, but while coconut
oil might be better than the saturated fats
in meats and butter, its benefits are not
as proven as all-mighty olive oil.